Hello Freak bitches.
So yeah,
you don't have a deep freezer.
We keep pot pies salted.
Like you said,
the w the world fought over salt for
ages and amazing to think about it today.
People were forced to work in
salt mines and died in them.
That was like as huge punishment for ages.
And there's a mountain in,
is it Germany?
There's a mountain of salt.
Wow.
It's been redeeming audit yet.
There's a book called
salt and it's very good.
Will you look up the book called Salt?
The guy who wrote it,
that and neighbor reducing just
because of the world's need for salt.
Yeah.
They just,
you know,
they dug it all down.
There's two mountains,
one in South America,
I can't remember the other.
And Mexico's it in Potosi and uh,
and there it has salt,
a world history.
You really like it now because he breaks
it down and he shows you the salt mines
and there's pictures of
the Salt Mountain and uh,
and it is unfucking believable.
I mean,
we were talking earlier today,
we were talking earlier today about not
having a smartphone would a big leap.
That would be to go back to a flip phone,
but look at the fuck
people fought over salt.
That is so alien and spices,
right?
The reason why Columbus was coming there,
it is that the reason why a Columbus was
a mountain of salt w w came and when I
always talk about Columbus
and even bloody show that it,
even Magellan,
and when he went around the world,
he sent five ships.
Uh,
they lost all of them.
They finally came back
with one three years later,
right?
Three years later,
but crappy ship with 18 guys sail back in.
Well,
it all been underwritten by,
uh,
businessmen from Germany,
right?
Who underwrote Magellan's voyage.
There was enough spice in that
ship to pay for the whole trip.
A three year trip and losing 300
guys in five ships or whatever,
four ships.
Whoa.
There was it because
they brought back what,
like,
why,
don't know what they wanted on that one.
Nutmeg or whatever it was.
And they had to go all the way around
the world to on would east indies,
no electricity.
But she see that was the difference was
Magellan was going to prove you could go
that way.
Right.
Cause usually they went around India and
the horn and so that's how valuable it
was.
And that's why,
uh,
English,
Portugal and Spain were such
giant powers that because spice,
and then when span took
over the new world,
there was a mountains of gold,
one in South American,
one amount of silver,
I mean a mountain silver that they
made the Indians and killed them all.
Doing it.
Dig Out and all the gold and silver
in Asia is still in circulation,
is like Spanish gold dug
out of the new world.
That's insane.
It was a literal mountain.
Two of them,
one in South America and one in Mexico.
Ted's still credible,
a mountain,
you know,
the real problem and things,
even the term social justice warrior
is that there are aggressive,
like the,
the thing about social justice.
So it's like what do you,
what do you,
what do you really want?
You want peace?
Guess where it,
guess what the worst way to
get pieces being an asshole.
Oh,
totally.
Being an asshole will almost
that kind of antisocial.
Yes.
There's a sense in
a lot of ways cause they're like,
like they're about doxing
people and aggressively
pursuing actions against them,
trying to get people fired because
they don't share their ideology.
The weirdest road testing.
Totally agree.
Like the weirdest thing to me.
And I think like people have
started to becoming more like,
I've certainly become more aggressive
just dealing with their shit,
you know what I mean?
Like become less aggressive
believe it or not about them.
Like I,
I don't,
I don't want to fight with that kind of
shit at all because I think it's just
creates a dust cloud of confused cause
it's counterproductive and it's totally
counterproductive.
And I share their beliefs
on a lot of things.
I just don't,
I don't share their methodology.
I don't share the,
the aggressive tactics and I just think
that what they're doing is like an
insanely short sided.
They think that their
Malcolm x or something,
they think that they're like trying
to fight the system by screaming,
yelling,
fuck capitalism.
And it's Kinda like the people
who are born like after the 60s,
like they were born after the party you,
I'm like,
and then you could tell that
it kind of pissed about it.
My friend,
my friend Andy Sarabia and I
were talking about this and uh,
uh,
we were talking a lot about like
how basically they target you.
Like,
all right,
so there are two gay guys who like had
Ted Cruz over just like chat with him,
right?
Because he's like running for president,
you know,
whatever.
And these guys were targeted by all of
these like gay social justice warrior
types being like,
just for talk,
just for talking to them
like you're mainstreaming,
his auntie gave you.
And like,
how are we supposed to persuade people
of our views if we can't even like talk
to them
to all of this creeping in.
And there's a concept of moral luck,
which is due to the
philosopher Thomas Nagel,
who,
who's done a lot of interesting work,
you know,
half of which I really agree with.
And some of it I don't,
but the concept of moral luck is that
it does seem unfair that there are many
situations in which people create immense
harms doing stuff that you and I have
gotten away with.
You know?
I mean,
they're not,
they're not worse people than we are.
They're like,
you know,
they,
you,
you and I have both driven
when we shouldn't have driven,
you know,
we had one beer,
too many or there were
there things that we did,
or you're,
you're looking at,
you look at a text,
you know,
and you know,
you should never look at your
phone when you're driving,
but you decide,
well,
I'm expecting a text.
And you look,
and there are people who are looking
at that text right now and just,
you know,
killing some child in the crosswalk,
right?
And their lives are going
to be ruined and you know,
they're going to go to prison and
they're exactly like you and me.
Right?
So there's a,
there's a,
there's an aspect of luck here,
but that the luck actually propagates
backward into the kind of brain you have,
the kind of upbringing you had,
the kind of parents you had,
the kind of,
you know,
the fact that you got hit in the head
as hard as you did or didn't and no one
has made themselves.
So,
um,
I'm a little bit more,
I'm less judgmental about some of
these things given my view of freewill,
but I'm not,
it's not that I'm not interested in
making the interventions that would make a
difference in whatever we could have
done to have gotten him to behave
differently.
We should have done whatever we should
need to do now to him to make society
better and to make him better and
to get restitution for the woman.
What we should do.
All that.
And so this doesn't tail locking up
certain dangerous people and it doesn't
tail.
Um,
you know,
we have to keep,
keep ourselves safe from people who
are going to reliably act badly.
And,
um,
and I don't know where he
falls on that spectrum,
but it's just,
it's not,
um,
the difference between the
feeling you get when you hear,
oh,
it was brain damage.
I sort of have that
feeling about everything.
You know,
if,
if we,
if he gets a brain scan,
if he goes to trial now he
gets a brain scan and we,
and we find that his brain is just
massively damaged and all the right areas
that would have eroded
his impulse control.
Right.
That would seem to let him
off the hook a little bit.
It would,
he would,
he would look like someone who is unlucky
more than he would look like a bad
person.
Right.
And I sort of see bad
people as unlucky to,
I recognize that there are certain people
who are quite classically bad people.
There are psychopaths who you,
not only can you not rely on them,
you,
you can rely on them to be bad actors,
you know,
so you,
you,
you have to,
you have to be in a posture of,
of self defense with
respect to these people.
But,
um,
I do view them as an unlucky on
some fundamental level.
It's the idea that you're going to arrive
at some point or that you're going to
land in this destination that
is called success or happiness.
And when you get to our age,
you realize that.
And that's just,
that's an illusion,
right?
It just continues.
And you start to think about,
you know,
what your life means.
What do you stand for
and what is your legacy?
You know,
it's like we're approaching 50.
It's like,
what do you know if I die today?
What was,
you know,
what did I,
what did I leave in my wake?
Well,
even that,
look,
the bottom line is whatever you leave,
it's not going to matter because it's
going to matter to some people that you
know and they're going to leave too.
Everyone's going to leave.
But are you enjoying this?
Are you enjoying the moment?
Everyone's working towards
this like ultimate,
like the retirement years,
the golden years,
you're fucking almost
dead when those years.
Cotton,
like those little,
you see those people like
holding hands and walking along,
they barely can walk.
Their knees hurt,
they're all fucked up.
Like that's not what you work for.
You don't work towards this ultimate
point where you don't do anything anymore
and that's ridiculous.
The way you should work towards is
doing what you enjoy doing right now and
enjoying your life right now and join
your friends right now and join whatever
hobbies you like to pursue.
Whatever,
you know,
love affairs and friendships and
all that stuff is what life is,
is life is the moment being in the moment.
And we somehow have turned it into this,
this weird like journey to
have a very specific point,
specific points of high school graduation,
college graduation,
but good job marriage,
children,
we have all these like milestones that
are supposed to impart happiness in this
race and they,
they're not real.
They're social constructs and we've,
we've created these social constructs and
we've fed into them and pass them down
from generation to generation without
anybody stepping back and going,
whoa,
who set this up?
Who set up,
who set up graduate school?
Who said it?
Who set up,
who set up common core?
Who?
Who are these people like Hawaii?
Why is,
why is it this way?
What does it,
we're just biological organisms trying
to have as much happiness and good
feeling while we're here as we can.
Okay.